in this video we're going to talk about
one of the most important US Supreme
Court cases that has helped determine
the balance of power between the federal
government and the states and that's
McCulloch versus Maryland so the year is
1816 where after the war of 1812 wars
are expensive the United States the
federal government wants to create the
second bank of the United States the
Charter for the first bank of the United
States had ended a few years ago and had
not been extended and the reason why a
bank is useful for a federal government
a bank can be a place to store taxes
that are collected from people it could
be a place to issue debts to issue
banknotes think paper currency and so
the second bank of the United States is
created it is headquartered in
Philadelphia right over here in 1816 and
that in 1817 they open up a branch in
Baltimore right over there and this is
where things get a little bit messy
because it turns out that the Maryland
legislature Baltimore is in Maryland
decides to pass a law to tax any banks
that have charters from outside of
Maryland well it turns out that the
branch of the second bank of the United
States was the only bank in Maryland
that was chartered outside of Maryland
and the law itself seems to be targeted
at that Bank the law taxes notes issued
by the bank the head of that branch of
the Baltimore branch of the second bank
of the United States James McCulloch he
refuses to pay this tax he says hey we
are a federally chartered bank you have
no right to taxes eventually it gets
appealed all the way to the United
States Supreme Court and there are two
main questions that need to be answered
the first is does the federal government
have the power to charter a National
Bank where is that in the United States
Constitution by the time it got to the
Supreme Court Maryland was arguing that
hey we don't even think the federal
government has the right to charter a
bank we don't see that enumerated in the
Constitution and then if the bank can
exist can estate
axé a National Bank the US Supreme Court
at this time is headed by Chief Justice
John Marshall who is a federalist and as
we will see they vote strongly in favor
of the federal government they decide
unanimously that yes the federal
government does have the power to
charter a bank and they say no a state
actually cannot tax it and so what do
they cite in the Constitution to back up
that decision so this right over here is
an excerpt of article 1 section 8 of the
United States Constitution we've covered
it in other videos when we talk about
enumerated powers and it lists a bunch
of powers enumerated just means things
that are very explicitly defined they've
been listed they've been enumerated
Congress has the power to lay and
collect taxes duties imposts and excises
borrow money regulate commerce with
foreign nations among the several states
with the Indian tribes and it goes on
and on and on but the 18th Clause here
is really interesting it's known as the
Necessary and Proper Clause and we cover
it in several other videos but it says
that Congress has the power to make all
laws which shall be necessary and proper
for carrying into execution the
foregoing powers and so John Marshall
the Chief Justice in his decision says
look even though the power to create a
National Bank to charter a National Bank
even though it isn't enumerated here in
article one section eight this Clause 18
this Necessary and Proper Clause says
that look the federal government also
can make laws that allow it that are
necessary and proper for doing the other
things for example borrowing money or
issuing currency and so they're saying
that look this bank is a means to an end
and because it is a means to an
enumerated end they're saying that
there's an implied power here and so the
whole notion of implied powers that we
talked about in other videos it really
strongly stems from this decision on
McCulloch versus Maryland now Maryland
argued a narrow reading of this
Necessary and Proper Clause they're like
what does a bank absolutely necessary
couldn't you do some of these other
things without having a bank and the
Supreme Court said well no no this isn't
to limit the federal government that
this whole section is all about anew
powers to say what the federal
government can do not what they can't do
so does not have to be absolutely
necessary and on the second question of
well if this banks going to exist can
the state the where the branches can the
state tax it that's where what's known
as the Supremacy Clause came into effect
this right over here is an excerpt
article six clause to this Constitution
and the laws of the United States which
shall be made in pursuance thereof and
all treaties made or which shall be made
under the authority of the United States
the federal government shall be the
supreme law of the land and the judges
in every state shall be bound thereby
and so the argument that the justices
made is well you could if you don't like
something if we allow the states to tax
this National Bank well the power to tax
is the power to destroy that you could
tax it so much that it can't even
operate but this is saying that the
authority of the federal government of
the United States shall be the supreme
law of the land so a state can't get in
the way of a federal government and to
hear it in John Marshall's own words he
wrote a very long a decision about
McCulloch versus Maryland but here's
just a few excerpts that speak to each
of these points so first of all implied
powers let the end be legitimate let it
be within the scope of the Constitution
and all means which are appropriate
which are plainly adapted to that end
which are not prohibited but consist
with the letter and spirit of the
Constitution are constitutional this is
a big deal he's saying look if the end
is legitimate and if the means is not
prohibited so nowhere in the
Constitution does it say that the
federal government can't start a
National Bank so it's not prohibited and
if it and if the end is to do some of
the enumerated powers that are
legitimate then it is constitutional so
this is really a strong wording around
implied powers and using the Necessary
and Proper Clause as the backing for it
and in terms of supremacy it is
the very essence of supremacy to remove
all obstacles to its action within its
own sphere and so to modify every power
vested in subordinate governments as to
accept its own operations from their
influence
so saying hey we're not gonna allow
subordinate government's the states to
get in the way that's the essence of the
supremacy clause this effect need not be
stated in terms it is so involved in the
declaration of supremacy so necessarily
implied in it that the expression of it
could not make it more certain so once
again John Marshall clearly saying the
Supremacy Clause in order for it to make
any sense the subordinate governments
the states should not be able to
interfere with the operations of the
federal government if their ends are
legitimate its constitutional and the
states cannot get in the way
in the example of McCulloch versus
Maryland by taxing so as you can imagine
this decision clarified the shifting of
a lot of power towards the federal
government and away from the states